Ford Motor Company has just announced it
will produce ventilators to help
overcome critical supply shortages it is
partnering with GE Healthcare to expand
production of much-needed vent
ventilators each month to treat
coronavirus patients some very good news
there Ford is also using its 3d printing
factories to produce plastic face
shields and respirator masks for
healthcare workers more good news
Jim Hackett is the president and CEO of
Ford Motor Company and he joins us from
Grand Rapids Michigan for his first TV
interview about this crisis
good morning mr. Hackett good morning
thank you for having me so to paraphrase
one of my favorite lines from Ford
versus Ferrari this is not the first
time that Ford Motor Company has gone to
war you made airplanes and military
equipment during World War two now in
the war against this virus you're gonna
be making ventilators so the big
question is how soon could we see
ventilators roll off a line that was
making Ford Explorers not too long ago
well I just want to confirm it is in our
history you know that is chronicled in
the arsenal of democracy about building
a bomber every 63 minutes we also
actually built ventilators way back in
history for premature babies and iron
lungs when there was the polio epidemic
so these are Ford folks at their best
this is a complicated product a
ventilator and there's two fronts that
were working on you mentioned the one
with GE I've talked to Larry called the
email and the teams are working really
closely there's a lot of different parts
that can be subdivided to suppliers and
then there's a parallel effort that the
Prime Minister Boris Johnson has asked
for our support in the UK we're working
with McLaren and Airbus and there's a
product there that's coming to market so
we're talking about producing hundreds
of thousands of these ventilators in the
future how long do you think it'll take
to get them to get them out to hospitals
well that's a great question you know
the problem is that the lines that have
been in place produce hundreds or
thousands we're talking about needing
hundreds of thousands just to put that
in perspective an f-150 one is built
every two 52 seconds so the ventilators
we need to scale as these collective
companies come to go we have to scale up
something like that
so we're talking about early June where
we don't think it's a problem but
between now and June it's about ramping
up and how exactly are you doing it Jim
since a lot of the Ford plants have
closed due to the corona virus how are
you guys making this happen
yeah that's a great question because
part of the place dependent work spaces
that require people to be on site a
factory is all about working together on
a line so the way these teams are
designing the production of this is
building some assemblies and smaller
groups and having them come together to
be assembled but we'll make extremely
safe places in fact let me just point
out that in addition to the ventilator
there's probably a bigger need for these
positive air pressure masks these are
masks that cover the face of our
caregivers that move air inside of it
this virus has a tendency to want to
enter through your I believe it or not
so the air helps protect them and we
have like in our cooling system in seats
we have little fans that we can backward
integrate into a new design for these
positive air pressure masks so those
products in addition to the ventilators
there's actually two or three different
versions of breathing apparatus that
we're working on hundreds of thousands
of the most simplest ones will be
starting to be produced in the next week
or so excited about both of those fronts
things active that is exciting news you
know shifting to the other part of this
crisis which is the economic portion of
it there are an estimated nine million
jobs tied in some way to the auto
industry from the assembly line all the
way to the car dealerships and we're
looking at estimates about ninety
percent drop in car sales in this month
as people stay home how is that going to
affect all those jobs well our primary
mission right now the waybill for
tonight talked about this and this is
you know this is the what you get with
family kind of derived companies our
first care is for our people back in o84
didn't take a bailout you know the
company borrowed enough money to take
care of itself back then we have a
fortress balance sheet today so what
we're trying to do
is get through this quarantine period
where everyone has a job and then on the
other side quickly rebuild demand and in
fact something came from our experience
in China where people continued to order
vehicles online so this is a really good
opportunity to have a scale up quickly
mr. hack and we're working really
closely with the UAW and there's there's
agreement that when it's time to go back
to work everyone's gonna go back to work
mr. hack and I very quickly I know
you've tapped into a fifteen billion
dollar line of credit to get through
this how long do you are you
anticipating it will last you know I
have in my head I think you know early
May because we can see what happened in
China we can see what happened in South
Korea and I'm hopeful that we get
started before then we're ready to go
hope you're right we hope you're right
yeah I could afford thank you so much
for being with us